around Cork City political posters gaze
down from the lampposts but it's
Ireland's healthcare crisis which the
voters want the politicians to look at
are you know what an infant of a woman I
had to bring him pillows for a mother
that's anger pillows so no that's the
Joker's lately if you have private
insurance it's it's it's fine there's no
problem well for the ordinary man in the
street it's not good to see people
waiting on trolleys for hours and hours
dr. Sarah Fitzgibbon has worked in a
deprived area of North Cork for the past
15 years her dedication is self evident
and so are her frustrations so a child
presenting today with mental health
issues that I feel and require a
specialist intervention if I put them on
a waiting list they might be seen in
four years time which is just that's not
a service in 2014 nearly three hundred
and fifty nine thousand outpatients were
on the public waiting list to see a
consultant by 2017 the number had risen
above half a million for the first time
and in 2019 it had grown to more than
five hundred and fifty three thousand to
try to tackle those relentless increases
in the waiting list the Irish government
is throwing millions every year of
public money into buying private health
care in 2019 it was the equivalent of 82
million dollars and this year it's going
to be closer to 110 million dollars and
still the waiting lists go up having
private health insurance meant that when
John Wall was diagnosed with terminal
prostate cancer in 2017 prompt treatment
helped extend his life in the time he
has left he's advocating urgent reform
frontline staff do their absolute to do
whatever they can given the resources
that they have but that's the problem
they don't have enough resources they
don't have enough beds they don't have
enough staff and the resources that are
being allocated is basically toying good
money after bad a universal health
proposal called slosher care has been
suggested but the different political
parties have very different ideas of
what to prioritize and how to implement
it so
really what's important here is that
population they're going to vote in the
next on Saturday are really looking for
change and it's a change in culture to
actually be citizen centered and to put
the politics aside to ensure that
everybody can have safe timely access to
health care it was the threat of a
no-confidence vote in Health Minister
Simon Harris which forced the Irish
t-shirt Leah Veronica to call this
election faced with the combination of
public anger and the sense that no one
was accepting responsibility on Saturday
in the polling booths the voters will
hold the politicians to account
Paul Brennan al Jazeera Limerick